um
so we were set a task we had 20 minutes
to find
a good property we came out here found
a 19 bed hmo anybody want to share what
happened what one of the deals you guys
got
so this one's it's a little bit
different um
because it's a 19 bed hmm okay
but it's over 300. yep i've spoke to the
agent who said they take 250. wow
it needs quite a lot of renovation but
there's it's already
letted um so three rooms are already
lighted
yeah um for 85 pounds a week
okay wow good it's also got a connected
to a pub
which pays 250 pounds a week so you own
a pub as well
so you get the pub as well and you've
just got hold on
and you've just agreed to buy it for 50
grand below he said he'd take 250.
where is it 20 minutes okay
not a great area but we don't like
beetle much but
the thing is even though it doesn't even
renovation free people already living
there so
okay technically leave it so it's got
the
rental potential of just under 100. see
you if you did rent it out though
you could value on a commercial
valuation
and then you could refinance it so that
sounds very interesting as well
where is it include thoughts
how much was the purchase price
well it was up at 70. yeah i spoke to
the agent and the agent said he'd take
they'd probably take offers
pass the mic on uh yeah to this
gentleman right here
uh go ahead what's your deal my friend
uh deal is uh
it's on offer for 70k yeah
and done up value the agent thinks it
could push it to 150.
and what's the refurb cost refurb cost
uh looking at the property
we anticipated it will be around like 40
to 45k
oh looking at the station
they sound like good deals you spoke to
the agents um
yes can we get a microphone on this lady
over here and there's a three bedroom
house
it's really really really unmodernized
it looked like it was somebody's grandma
where is it
home purchase price 100
000 refurb uh 20 000
and value 200 000.
okay okay good good good oh cause you're
gonna shout out on whichever guess that
i hear the most it's gonna come on stage
pub
we got clethops
we got wrexham and we've got
hull on the count of three i want you to
shout which one you want to see
we'll get him up on the stage one two
three go
hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on one sec
one sec the problem is the problem is
pop and hull kind of sounds similar so
if you guys could grab a seat
give these guys both a massive hand
okay so now we're gonna have house or
pub all right and you're gonna shout
which one you want you want pub house
house pub ready and go
all right well done give her a big hand
all right please give it up for this
gentleman right here give him a hand
give him a man
what's your name brother his name is
josh everybody it's josh
all right josh where you from what's
your story i'm literally
three minutes away from me if three
swish into the area well
yeah call this gym good good
so this pub as you know the area wow
the area boot or the thing that worried
me about the pub was built or i've heard
bad things about bootable yeah it's not
the best i've
said okay there's obviously there's
opportunity
okay and what but you got to sell us
more than that
you can't just go yeah it's in a bad
area but opportunity like
well the thing is there's 16 vacant
rooms okay
it's already taking over 2k months
even on a repayment mortgage it's
already covered
yeah how are you going to fill those
other rooms if they're not filled now
what makes you that you can fill them
renovate them okay so they're in bad
condition have you got the postcode
all right l24qt
it's called l24q
but it's definitely not a cutie
well let's find out in a moment okay
here we go guys
so this is the property right here yes
so this is the property guys
he rang them up tell me how the
conversation went when you called them
um i basically said that i said i'm a
property sourcer i want to find
you know deals for investors what is the
better sort of the lowest
that they would take and still be happy
okay okay and they said 250.
yeah well he said what were you thinking
i said well
what about 250 and he said i said if it
was tomorrow
yeah it looks it looks quite a good
building
it looks quite a good building so if you
bought it for 250 grand
you would be able to get a commercial
valuation based on that
if you rent it if you renovate it and
rented it out you can get a commercial
valuation because commercial
properties are varied based on rents um
so
what do you think the end value would be
if you if you've refurbed it and
renovated it
it must be half a mill it must be
[Music]
ring the agent and ask them how much it
would be if it was done up nice
i i just called um earlier on about room
rose road you know the 19
[Music]
do you think that would be if it was all
renovated to a nice standard and fully
rented out
and also for 300 now um
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
all right all right so
she just said she would get a valuer
to go research calling back by the way
thank you for letting me use your phone
give her a hand as well
go ahead as well right now when the
valuer gives you your end value let's
say it's i don't know half a million
or whatever it might be then you know
the purchase price is 250
then all you need to do is work out what
the renovation is going to be
and then you can do your figures if it
works if it's a pull your money out deal
that's the kind of project where you can
pull a joint venture partner in and
retire off one deal or sell it for 20
grand
so good job what did you learn
the deals are out there you've just got
to take action
yeah because that's not far from me
finally
you've got an option now who's your team
by the way it was literally just me and
my
girlfriend oh so you know when i said
go strangers
good all right could you pass kelly in
the microphone caitlyn did you know this
morning when you woke up that you'd be
on stage in front of 200 people later
okay the reason i want you on stage is
because the moment i'm enough just to
make a decision
and i wanted you to be able to be part
of the decision process as you found the
deal together
because here's the decision here's the
decision option number one
is you can receive 200 pounds
hard cash i'll put it in your hand right
now geez i got i got money
believe me i got money okay so here you
go 100 pounds
cash 100 pounds cash so i can give you
800 pounds each
and then uh i'll call back that lady
and continue with the deal just to leave
it's only a lead at the moment
option number two is you can say
actually samuel i'm going to stick
around for the rest of the day
and learn about joint ventures and
raising finance and
i don't want your money i just want to i
just want to continue with this deal so
those are your two options
obviously you need time to think about
it so i'm going to give you a chance to
have a meeting
about this you can get together have a
conversation so you can have 15 seconds
to have a meeting and you're because how
many rules that
business people make quick decisions yes
or no
15 seconds go oh
all right before you tell us if what do
you think they're going to go
the cash or the deal what do you reckon
come on cash or deal
right drum roll drum roll drum roll drum
roll all right
all right josh what are you guys
deciding i'm going to take the cash
all right and
there's the money the proof is in the
pudding so i'll be honest i've watched a
lot of these videos sometimes you think
it's not real
it's too good to be true we're not
actors we're real people
we've made money before lunch so get
down
get involved and take action